well y'all got javel mcgee now on the
mavericks yes sir you know he makes
beats yeah he hear me that's what matter
of fact i gotta call the [ __ ] when i'm
out here because i think he had her but
he moved into that he had hit me the
other day so he's on the mavericks now
you guys got him
you also let jaylen brunson walk right
out that [ __ ] door that was true that
was
why did they do that well he wasn't
consistent enough or something well he's
he's got family that's wrapped up in the
knicks organization that's why mark
cuban is going after uh there was like
tampering going on pretty much mark
cuban saying he they never had a chance
to keep him because he'd already made
his mind if he's going to the knicks oh
so basically that was just his it's like
his dad or his brother some [ __ ] or both
are like a part of the knicks
organization and oh but yeah y'all have
not had the greatest offseason i'd
expected y'all to like land a name i
mean javale's a great there we go we got
what's bro from houston we got we got
somebody from houston who uh the center
right center from houston from the
rockets [ __ ] i don't know if there's
we got somebody right before him
right before mcgee
i don't know
what what's brother look look that [ __ ]
up hello i know this i know
that y'all need another [ __ ] score
at least tim hardaway yeah tim hardaway
i feel bad for luca luca reminds me you
know that meme remember during the
popeye's chicken craze there's that meme
of that lady sitting out of popeye's
just tired as [ __ ] i feel like i feel
like that's luca he's just carrying the
whole team you know what i'm saying but
y'all y'all beat us jason kidd is a
[ __ ] hell of a coach
great coach
shout out to jay kidd man do you have
like season tickets to the mavericks of
the cowboys christian wood
yeah is that him christian wood okay
that's fair great pickup that's what we
got christian wood
center power forward yeah yeah i forgot
christian wood yeah for sure i mean
we're gonna eat hard no he's great but
he hurt but he's not like a ball handler
man we'll get all this [ __ ]
who's the backup point guard who's the
[ __ ] shooting guard it's tim hardaway
jr who's else handling who else is
handling the kyle mark and i'm gonna say
i'm gonna give him some id can you call
mark cuban i really can't wanna see a
taste mix yeah show me that
tell that [ __ ] come on my show
[ __ ]
i met mark cuban when i was like and you
know what's crazy another person bro i
never think that i could even
takes a column and have conversation and
he literally if i was to shoot him a
text he'll lose like shoot back that's
amazing that's crazy right does he ever
give you any investment advice no i
ain't never asked somebody i know she
likes that's where you're [ __ ] up not
[ __ ] i haven't done it just be like hey
man i'm trying to see we be talking a
little bit on that [ __ ] hey yo
mark cuban got green bubbles boys green
bubbles he got that android
green bubbles mark cuban got that
android i i probably got the android
[ __ ] i don't know you have you have
three well you have two phones uh is are
they both iphones yeah okay so you don't
even [ __ ] with the androids
ever at life yeah but i i it i got a uh
iphone probably like 2 000
end of 2016
yeah i was team android for so long and
two chainz ones and one of his songs
said uh trapping i'm live two chainz
said uh trapping on my android in like
2012 and i was like yes
and then the next time i saw him he had
an iphone i was like bro
what the [ __ ] i thought you were
trapping on your [ __ ] android bro
time's shane my brother i mean i got an
iphone now so there's that